.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Parlons-en, justement de ce
que c'est d'abord Est-Ouest. Ou
est-ce que c'est situé? Où est
le siège social?
- C'est une organisation
internationale à des siège se
trouve à Bruxelles.
C'est écrit dans les années 70
pour venir sécuriser les
échanges interbancaires c'est un
système de communication qui
permet à des banques
quotidiennement à hauteur de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'opérations par jour d'échanger
de manière sécurisée sur des
flux financiers internationaux
et nationaux. Après est-ce que
la Russie en a besoin? Est-ce
que c'est crucial pour ce pays?
- C'est nécessaire pour la
Russie parce qu'elle fait partie
et au-delà. Dès que la Russie
souhaite échanger avec d'autres
banques, elle se sert également
du reste pour effectuer les
opérations un petit peu.- Si one
système, quel genre de
désorganisation cela peut causer
pour ce pays?
- Assez massive parce que c'est
un système qui est en place
depuis près de 50 ans. C'est un
système qui est le système
privilégié par les banques pour
des communications sur des
opérations simples mais aussi
complexes. Par exemple tout ce
qui est documentaire. Tout ce
qui est la garantie que la
banque peuvent émettre sur des
projets internatio
complexes. C'est par Swift et
que cela passe. De là pas avoir
accès à cela, on peut suivre
John Adassie de possie de possir
communiquer de manière
structurée avec les partenaires
financiers.
- Est-ce que ça pourrait
étoufferement la
Russie?
que Swift peut étouffer
la Russie? Je ne pense pas. Je
pense que c'est le cumul de
Ploemeur chance. Je pense que ls
sanctions prises par les pays
occidentaux comme le Canada,
une troisième vague de sanctions
aujourd'hui, les États-Unis
également. Les pays européens
adoptent des sanctions contre le
secteur bancaire qui ne sont qui
vise les principales banques
accumule des sanctions contre
les banques et privés la Russie
des Swift pourrait sur les
moyens eés
étouffer le système bancaire.
- Puisque la Russie est déjà
dans un ue, pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas déjà joué
cette carte de la retirer du
système Swift?
sait pas ce qu'il set. On a un t
ça ira en 2012. Depuis 2010 ôtés
à nouveau. On essaie pas. Les
rangs il y a des liens
commerciaux importants mais quie
l'Occident entretient avec la
Russie. On ne sait pas. C'est
comme si on appuyait sur le
bouton sans savoir exactemen
qui allait se passer. On ne sait
pas qui vont être les
conséquences pour les banques
partenaires de certaines
institutions russes. On sait
qu'en Europe, en Allemagne et
l'Italie, ils se sont opposés à
cette option. Ils ont peur de ne
pas pouvoir payer le gaz.
De grossences.ences.ences.ences.
- Il y a des pays qui font
affaire avec la Russie et il y a
tout ce secteur lié aux
ressources génétiques pour
l'Europe. Il y a un lien de
dépendance très fort de
l'Allemagne par la Russie. Ner a
peut dire qu'on se prive. On
pourrait avoir une crise
énergétique. Est-ce que vous
êtes en train de dire.
- C'est ça. Après ça pourrait
aussi inciter la Russie à ne pas
poursuivre ces experts en
hydrocarbures et d le le le le e
rap actuellement besoin. Donc,
cette crestestestestestestestest
aujourd'hui admis dans un nombre
de pays mêmes si on voit de plus
en plus de par exemple le
conseil de l'union européenne à
évaluer sur ce point, on se
range derrière le Canada et le
Royaume-Uni et la France et les
États-Unis qui semblent de plus
en plus considérer cette option
au fur et à mesure de la
progression de la situation.
- Qu'est-ce que vous décodez de
l'empressement de certains pays
dépassait cette option alors que
d'autres sont plus frileux?
Certains ont moins à perdr
retrait de l'Allemagne de ce
système que d'autres. Des gens
sont dans une position un peu
moins fragile et finalement.
- Oui. Tout dépend finalement de
la balance commerc
a avec la Russie. Il y a des
pays qui sont plus ou moins
exposés à la Russie. Je pense
, le Canad, le Canad, le Canad,t
exposé mais si on devait se
priver de certains expand
Russie, moins les conséquences
directes sur le consommateur sur
ns des pays
comme l'Allemagne et l'Italie,
il faut que vous imaginiez que
pour un exemple très client,
l'Autriche plus de 90 % de son
gaz et en provenance de Russie.
C'est demain les apports des
faits à stopper, on a une crisee
massive des gaz qui aura affecté
le consommateur autrichien.- Lae
entendait encore être la Russie
de Swift. Mais est-ce qu'elle se
fait commander par la commun
internationale ou est-ce que
c'est un niveau d'autonomie ce
système?
- C'est un systè
autonomie. C'est Swift qui
choisit ses clients. Il fournit
des services à des
établissements bancaires. C'est
vrai que cela peut paraître un
peu paradoxal, mais pour autant
on a quaIl
faut le souligner. En 2018 quand
Donald Trump et les États-Unis
ont sorti de l'accord de Vienne,
les états européens n'étaientalc
cette position. Il a eu un grand
débat entre les États-Unis et ss
points. Il a été décidé par les
Américains d'imposer dess qui va
fourniture et qui visait Swift.
Elle a eu à choisir entre
prendre le risque de sanctionner
les États-Unis, au continué les
services. Dans ce cas l'option
était simple. On se range à
l'Amérique.
- Il y a
monde des affaires et parfois
aveugle. Protège ses propres
intérêts. C'est ce que vous êtes
- C'est un peu cela. Même si
Swift est autonome et même si
c'est une organisation...
les lois américaines et une très
forte. Quand on risque desls dea
part de cette loi on a tendance
par volonté de se conformer àdet
pas forcément dans ses propres
intérêts.